and object moving freely from one point
to another we'll take a path of least
action imagine throwing a ball that will
go up then come down in an arc and it
will do this every time but how does
everyone know to take the same path why
doesn't it take some wibbly-wobbly
imagined path the reason is that the
ball is lazy it wants to take the path
of least resistance and waste as little
energy as possible if you were to
calculate the kinetic energy from speed
at every point on the path and subtract
from that the potential energy from its
height the number you would get is
called the action and you would find
that this action is the minimum for the
true path of the ball tanks so if
everything is about a minimum path then
why doesn't the ball just travel in a
straight line why does it arc well at a
high point we have a lot of potential
energy the quantity of kinetic minus
potential is negative and because we
care about the average over the whole
path a negative value will bring our
average down which is what the ball once
on the other hand you can't go up too
far because that will involve
a lot of kinetic energy you have to go
fast to get up so high it turns out that
the solution is a balance between trying
to get a lot of potential energy with
the least amount of extra kinetic energy
possible the principle of least action
was one of physicist Richard Feynman's
favorite ideas and one of the curious
things about it is wondering how the
ball or the object knows which is the
path of least action does it sniff out
all of the neighboring paths in the case
of light when we put blocks in the way
so that the photons could not sniff out
all the paths we found that they
couldn't figure out which way to go
and we got the phenomenon of diffraction
the light essentially spread out taking
every possible path the amazing thing is
that this is also true in quantum
mechanics the particle doesn't just take
the right path but it looks at all
possible trajectories
if by having things in the way we don't
let it look then we get an analogue of
diffraction a probability that it could
be found in a number of different places